je suis sportive
belle intelligente
souriante et pourtant je me suis cramé
j'ai fait un burn-out
je me suis épuisé professionnellement
pour moi toute forme de dépression
qu'elle soit d'origine personnelle ou
professionnelle était la marque d faible
la marque de ceux qui ne savent pas se
battre de ceux qui ne savent pas
profiter de la vie cela ne pouvait donc
pas m'arriver
les gens autour de moi pensaient
d'ailleurs comme moi ce test un burnout
impossible il son énergie si j'ai décidé
de vous raconter mon histoire c'est
parce que je sais que pour la plupart
des sourires que je vois en face de moi
ce sont de vrais sourires mais je sais
aussi que pour certains d'entre vous il
ne s'agit que d'en sourire de façade
cherché à dissimuler un mal être profond
une fatigue extrême
alors j'ai envie de vous dire pour vous
ou pour vos proches pour maintenant ou
pour plus tard comment j'ai fait ce burn
out et comment je crois aujourd'hui que
c'est ce qui m'a sauvé parce que je suis
aller droit dans le mur et j'ai envie de
vous faire éprouver le chemin sans que
vous n'ayez en éprouver le prix alors
l'histoire commence bien je suis
diplômés de grenoble école de management
vous verrez on y arrive
je suis amoureuse désolé j'ai envie de
me trouver un travail à grenoble parce
que j'aime la nature et j'ai envie de
continuer à pratiquer les sports qui me
passionne du tennis et du ski j'ai envie
de mordre la vie à pleines dents de
monter de nombreux projets de travailler
dans un domaine qui a du sens pour moi
et je suis heureuse
le jour où je signe mon cdi pour un
cabinet de conseil en développement
durable
j'ai intégré une petite structure et
très vite il ya un fort besoin de
compétences et de preuve de
professionnalisme alors je m'éclate sur
des projets ambitieux dans mes
interlocuteurs je compte des vice
présidents de grandes entreprises
je déjeune à l'assemblée nationale tarn
et projet implique des députés et des
ministres
et dans cette euphorie je réalise même
une de mes plus belles saisons de tennis
et puis quand je parle de mon job à mes
amis la plupart ont des étoiles dans les
yeux j'ai des responsabilités je
développe mon réseau mon job a du sens
l'oeuvre pour un développement durable
je ne vends pas des cigarettes pour un
géant du tabac
alors je me souviens avoir eu ma mère au
téléphone un fort je rentrais du travail
c'est vrai que mes journées commencent
et à s'allonger elle me le fait
remarquer je suis un peu la maline je
l'envoie promener en lui disant que je
travailler 70 heures cette semaine mais
que franchement je ne vois pas où est le
problème
parce que j'ai cette phrase de confucius
en tête
choisissez un job que vous aimez et vous
n'aurez pas à travailler un seul jour de
votre vie et je suis d'accord avec
confucius est ce que je tisse ma vie g
je suis à fond j'adore et pour moi
répondre oui à cette première question
est largement suffisant il n'y a que ça
qui m'importe
il n'y a que ça qui importe tout court
alors je suis d'accord avec confucius et
je kiffe ma vie et en même temps sans
vouloir me l'avouer sans vouloir le
reconnaître je sens au fond que le
rythme que j'imprime commence
sérieusement à me fatiguer pas grave je
vous rappelle que j'ai absolument toutes
les qualités pour y faire face et je ne
suis franchement pas du genre à me
laisser impressionner par un peu de
fatigue alors je redouble d'intensité je
me jette encore plus dans le travail je
continue à faire autant de sport voire
plus c'est ma façon à moi d'évacuer le
stress mais je commence sérieusement à
prendre beaucoup moins de plaisir à
aller travailler
j'ai du mal à m'endormir où je me
réveille dans la nuit en pensant au
boulot alors je me dis hein que c'est
stupide que j'ai mon amoureux qui dort à
côté de moi et que c'est ça le plus
important
mais mes insomnies sont de plus en plus
régulières un soir je me retrouve chez
mes parents mes frères et soeurs sont la
skin occasion rare on ne voit pas
beaucoup envie aux quatre coins de la
france et puis dans ma famille on rigole
beaucoup
mais là j'arrive pas à rigoler à l'orge
affiche un sourire de façade
je leur fait croire que je suis là mais
je suis pas là alors je quitte la pièce
pour aller pleurer un coup en me disant
que j'en ai marre de ce rythme de fou
qu'il faudrait que ça change
mais en même temps je me dis aussi que
je ne peux pas que jeune que je n'y
arriverai pas et que j'ai beau en parler
à mon employeur j'ai l'impression qu'il
ne comprend pas quelques mois plus tard
je me retrouve aussi chez des amis mon
ami me demande comment va mon travail je
lui réponds que comme d'habitude je suis
fatigué que je me sens très c'est qu'il
faudrait que ça change
elle me demande alors combien de fois
encore
vais-je entendre cette phrase dans ta
bouche
sans que tu te donne réellement les
moyens de changer quoi que ce soit dans
ta vie je l'envoie promener en lui
demandant pour qui elle se prend en lui
demandant d'arrêter de me faire
culpabiliser en lui disant que ma vie
est déjà assez compliqué comme ça et que
je n'attends clairement pas de mes amis
qu'il m'enfonce encore un peu plus elle
ne voit donc pas que je n'y arrive pas
que je n'arrive pas à faire autrement
qui a une force intérieure qui m'oblige
à aller dans ce sens-là je travaille sur
le volet social du développement durable
cela signifie que mon job est de faire
en sorte de générer une performance
durable auprès des organisations
une performance durable où l'individu
est au service du résultat mais demeure
plus important que lui et je suis
profondément humaniste donc j'accompagne
les organisations à générer de la
performance en travaillant sur la
génération de la confiance de
l'optimisme du bien-être et en
l'occurrence j'anime une formation
auprès de managers une nouvelle
formation
pour leur part les destine de soi
d'assertivité et donc du fait de savoir
dire non et là je peux vous assurer que
j'ai beau être au fond du trou je me
rends compte de l'ironie du du truc je
suis formatrice en bien-être au travail
et je dresse encore une fois l'amer
constat que je vis l'exact opposé
quelques jours après je croise un
collègue qui me demande comment je vais
hélas j'éclate en sanglots
ma carapace vient d'exploser
je pensais encore être protégés par ce
bouclier
je voulais encore cacher ce qui
m'arrivait franchement je n'assume pas
d'être cette fille là qui ne va pas bien
qu'il pleure qui pleurnichent
mais enfin je lui raconte ce qui
m'arrive vraiment je lui dis que la nuit
d'avant je les passais tout seul au fond
du lit de ma chambre d'hôtel à pleurer
sans savoir pourquoi sans en parler à
personne que la seule énergie qu'il me
reste et pour bloquer dans la
téléréalité devant les anges de la télé
réalité où les ch'tis débarque à mykonos
que j'ai commencé à prendre des
somnifères que j'adore le contact avec
les gens mais que je ne supporte plus
d'entendre la sonnerie de mon téléphone
mon collègue me demande alors combien de
temps encore
as tu décidé d'aller mal avant d'aller
mieux
cette question me fait un mal incroyable
parce que je me rends compte de
l'énormité de ma propre bêtise et ce
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
je suis au fond du trou à des années
lumières d'un principe latin qui est
fondamental pour moi depuis que je suis
toute petite
men sana in corpore sano un corps sain
dans un esprit sain mais je me suis
aveugle et j'ai confié mon bien-être à
quelqu'un d'autre que moi j'ai cru
pipeauté tiquement un jour on
s'occuperait de moi je comprends alors
que c'est bien moi la responsable qui
est perpétré ce système qui me fait tant
de mal que c'est moi la responsable de
cette situation toxiques pour moi la
deuxième raison pour laquelle ça me fait
aussi mal c'est que je me rends compte
de mon arrogance du fait que
vraisemblablement mon ego est
surdimensionné je suis un être humain
pourvu certes de nombreuses qualités
mais qui comme tout le monde a ses
limites et j'ai été prévenu alerté
informé par mon corps par mon amoureux
par mes proches et j'ai tellement
présumé de mes forces que je n'étais
qu'à pas venir les écouter eu ni de
m'écouter mois
le déclic a donc enfin lieu j'ai alors
pleinement conscience que je ne vais pas
bien pleinement conscience qu'il ya
dorénavant une seconde question qui est
importante
suis-je en forme suis-je en santé c'est
à dire non pas seulement pas malade mais
bien comme l'affirment l'organisation
mondiale de la santé depuis 1946 dans un
état complet de bien-être physique
mental et social
commence alors la troisième étape celle
d'aller mieux
et même mieux encore celle d'aller bien
mais je ne sais plus comment faire je
suis un peu démunis et lit alors une
troisième question qui m'a été d'une
grande utilité
et si je n'avais pas peur qu'est ce que
je ferai cette question était
véritablement le point de départ de ma
nouvelle vie et si je n'avais pas peur
qu'est ce que je ferais je quitterai mon
travail je prendrais de très longues
vacances ce que je n'avais pas
franchement eu le temps de faire avant
je perdrais des heures à ne rien faire
ce que je ne savais pas à faire et c'est
ce que j'ai fait j'ai osé inscrire
sciemment un trou dans mon cv et
finalement j'ai mis ce temps à profit
comment en travaillant sur moi en
plaçant enfin cette énergie non plus
pour foncer mais bien pour comprendre ce
qui pour comprendre et construire ce qui
est important pour moi et c'est fait
confiance à tuci clide qui dès le 5e
siècle avant notre ère nous disait le
secret du bonheur c'est la liberté et le
secret de la liberté c'est le courage
alors j'aime dire que j'ai pris le temps
de travailler les bases de mon écologie
personnel et ce n'est pas que pour le
marketing que je vous dis ça je suis
vraiment sérieuse en disant que j'ai
pris le temps de définir mon rythme mais
besoin mes valeurs mes envies mes désirs
et à les mettre vraiment en application
à me rendre compte qu'il est dorénavant
plus important pour moi de profiter des
montagne enneigée et ensoleillée
plutôt que de me sentir coincé au bureau
à me rendre compte qu'il est dorénavant
plus important pour moi d'être en forme
pour pouvoir profiter de mes amis plutôt
que de faire croire comme beaucoup
autour de moi que je me sens graphie
fier et comblé par des journées speed
est bien remplie de 15 heures de travail
c'est pour ça que je dis aujourd'hui que
le burn-out m'a sauvée parce que je vais
enfin dans la direction qui est
importante pour moi je laisse enfin
s'exprimer mon intelligence émotionnelle
et je ne me laisse plus définir parce
que les gens les organisations attendent
prétendument deux mois et une fois que
j'avais fait ce plein d'énergie sachant
maintenant que derrière chaque peur il
ya en réalité un désir
j'ai décidé de continuer à oeuvrer pour
mes désirs j'ai réalisé un rêve de gosse
celui de monter ma boîte
alors ça fait souvent sourire les gens
quand je prends le raccourci suivant
j'ai fait un burn out et donc je monte
ma boîte
j'en profite alors pour faire part aux
personnes qui me le demandent des deux
processus de régulation que je me suis
fixé
le premier c'est de prendre autant de
vacances que je le veux mais que jo le
temps nécessaire et le deuxième c'est de
faire du sport une créer une priorité
dans mon agenda
je peux vous assurer que mes clients et
partenaires savent très bien que je ne
réponds pas à leurs mails à la minute
près
et quant à leur pose un problème
je leur réponds que selon moi le projet
professionnel n'est en réalité qu'un
seul élément de l'ensemble du projet de
vie généralement ils se mettent à
scanner leur propre vie et me laisse
tranquille
je viens donc de partager avec vous les
cinq dernières années de ma vie pour
voulait résumer en trois phrases j'ai
envie de vous dire que j'ai d'abord vécu
à 200 à l'heure et que j'ai trouvé ça
absolument géniale est suffisant jusqu'à
ce que je me rende compte que j'avais
définitivement trop tirer sur la corde
et que j'étais en train de le payer très
cher
j'ai alors modifier ma façon de
fonctionner en eau entreprendre des
actions en lien avec mes mes désirs et
mes besoins je viens donc de partager
avec vous comment j'ai travaillé mon
bien-être
comment je continue à le travailler en
répondant constamment à ces trois
questions est-ce que je m'éclate dans ce
que je fais est ce que je suis en forme
équilibré dans les piliers de vie et si
je n'avais pas peur qu'est ce que je
ferais je crois et donc répondre oui à
l'une de ces questions étaient
suffisants je sais aujourd'hui pour
l'avoir vécu qu'il est absolument
nécessaire de veiller à formuler
constamment ces trois questions en même
temps et qu'il est nécessaire
d'engranger des actes qui réponde
favorablement à chacune de ses trois
interrogations
ces questions ont définitivement changé
ma façon de voir le monde
ma façon d'être au monde est finalement
ma façon de réussir et ses trois balises
peuvent vous permettre à votre tour de
travailler sur votre bien-être
d'investir pour votre bien-être mais il
est maintenant de votre propre
responsabilité de savoir si vous
préférez la jouer ego surdimensionné ou
en accord avec vous même et pour vous
aiguiller dans votre propre réflexion
je conclurai en citant john lennon quand
je suis allé à l'école ils m'ont demandé
ce que je voulais êtres quand je serai
grand j'ai répondu heureux
ils m'ont dit que je n'avais pas compris
la question
j'ai répondu qu'il n'avait pas compris
la vie
merci